Let's do a couple of problems
where we estimate or predict
answers to questions using
linear models.
It sounds very fancy.
But what a linear model is is
just using a line to describe
some trend in data.
With our linear models we
will do a little bit of
interpolation and a little
bit of extrapolation.
You might have already heard
these words before in your
everyday life.
Interpolation means trying to
estimate what happened between
two data points.
We're going to do a couple
of examples of
that in this video.
Extrapolation means we'll see
what the last few data points
were, and see what that trend
would look like, and then keep
on continuing that trend and see
what might happen if that
trend were to continue.
I'll show you some
examples of that.
So let's do some example
questions here.
So I have this chart here.
Median age, remember median
is the middle.
So if I have the numbers 3, 7,
and 9, the median is the 7.
It's the middle age.
So this is the median age of
males and females at first
marriage by year.
So if we just look at this data
right here, if we look at
1900, the average man was
getting married, not the
average, the median male.
So the middle man was getting
married at looks like at
around the age a little over
25, almost 26, while the
median woman was getting married
looks at around 22 or
23 years old.
As we went through the century,
those ages got lower,
and lower, and lower, until
we got to about 1960.
This problem is interesting
irrespective
of the actual problem.
It's just interesting to see
this trend that at the
beginning of the century, people
got married reasonably
similar to when they're getting
married right now.
But there was a minimum point.
Around the 1960s, people got
married at a younger age.
This was true for males
and females.
You can also see back here the
age difference between the
median male and the
median female.
That's just gotten smaller
and smaller over time.
Now it's really small.
So these are just
all interesting
things from this chart.
This is the actual data
from that chart.
So actually I didn't even have
to estimate it here.
In 1900, the median age of
males getting married was
25.9, that's that right there,
and the median age of women
getting married was 21.9,
that's that over there.
So this is just a scatter
plot of this data.
We've just plotted each of these
points over here, these
in blue, these in red.
Let's do the questions.
Use the data from example 1--
this is example 1 up here-- to
estimate the age at marriage
for females in 1946.
Fit a line by hand to the
data before 1970.
So what they want to do, is they
want me to look at all of
the data before 1970.
So let's see, this is
1970 right here.
That's 1970 right there.
They want to fit a line by hand
to the data before 1970.
What they mean is-- and I'm just
going to eyeball -- but
they want me to draw a line that
gets as close to all of
this data before 1970
as possible.
So it can't go through
all of these points.
Because all these points don't
sit exactly on one line.
But let me try to draw a line,
or a linear model, for the
data from, what is this, 1890
all the way to 1970.
So I'm going to try my best to
draw a line here that gets
close to all of these points.
It won't be able to go
through all of them.
So all the way to 1970, maybe
a line would look
something like that.
Let me draw a better
one than that.
I'll draw it in red because
we're dealing
with the red data.
So I want to go all
the way to 1970.
It would have been nice to
have a line drawing tool.
Maybe the line might look
something like that.
There are actual mathematical
ways to figure out the best
fit line on this.
We won't go into
that right now.
That's called linear
regression.
But I just eyeballed it.
That line looks like a pretty
good fit for all of that data.
None of the data is too far
away from that line.
So that's what they mean by fit
a line by hand to the data
before 1970.
This is the data before 1970.
If we assume that this is a
good linear model for that
data, we can use it to estimate
the age at marriage
for females in 1946.
Let's see, this is 1950.
This would be 1945.
1945 would be right over here.
So 1946 would be right
over there.
So if we wanted to estimate
that, if I were to figure out
where that hits the vertical
axis, it seems to hit the
vertical axis at around-- I
don't know, my best to guess
is, I should have zoomed
in more-- it hits
it right about there.
This is 22.5.
So this looks like maybe 20.5.
Because this would be
maybe 20.5 years.
So I'll call it twenty
20.5 years.
Obviously I can't do it exact,
but you get the idea.
I am interpolating.
Here I'm using the
model to do.
I won't use necessarily the
word interpolation yet.
We're going to do a much more
direct form of interpolation
later on in this video.
But here I fit a line, and then
I just use that line as a
model to estimate what was the
median age of women in 1946.
Let's do part 2.
Use the data from example 1 to
estimate the age of marriage
for females in 1984.
Fit a line by hand to the data
from 1970 on in order to
estimate this accurately.
So now they want us to fit
a line from the data on.
So let me make a line.
So fit a line by hand from
the data 1970 on.
So let me draw a line that gets
close to all of these
points, that gets close
to describing
all of these points.
Maybe it looks like something
like that.
Not all of them sit exactly on
the line, but they're all
pretty close.
If we assume that this is a
good a linear model-- I
haven't done this
mathematically, I'm eyeballing
it-- but let's see what
it would be in 1984.
This is 1990.
So 1984 is going to be
right around there.
Actually it looks amazingly
similar to the median age of
men in 1970.
So we can actually get
the exact number.
It's about 23.2.
So this looks to be
about 23.2 years.
Part 3, use the data from
example 1 to estimate the age
at marriage for males in 1995.
Use linear interpolation.
Now we're going to do more
direct form of interpolation.
We're not going to use a linear
model or we're not
going to fit a line.
We're going to use linear
interpolation between 1990 and
2000 data points.
We're looking at men now.
So I'll do it in blue.
Between 1990, that is 1990
and that is 2000 for men.
So if I were to draw just a line
there, we could assume
that the trend would have looked
something like that
between 1990 and 2000.
They want us to interpolate
what happened in 1995.
So 1995 is that point
right there.
So this is pure interpolation.
We're using the data point
in 1990 and the
data point in 2000.
We're drawing a line between
them and assuming that 1995
would have been right
in between them.
We're interpolating between
the 1990 data
and the 2000 data.
So if you were to try to
estimate where that is, it
looks like it's a little
bit over 26.
Actually if we say that it's
right in between these two
values right there, it'll
be 26.45 years.
If it's exactly in between,
1995 is exactly
5 years from each.
So 26.45 looks pretty good.
So let's do another example So
here's a percentage of women
smokers by year.
I have to say these charts
are interesting in and of
themselves.
You'll notice in 1990 there were
a good number of women
who were pregnant who smoked.
Almost 18% or 19% of pregnant
women smoked in 1990.
Now that's down.
Well this is 2004 so hopefully
this trend is continuing to go
down eventually to 0%.
But it went down to 10%.
So there still are a percentage
of pregnant women
who unfortunately smoke.
Let's do these problems. Use
the data from example 2--
that's this right here-- to
estimate the percentage of
pregnant smokers in 1997.
Use linear interpolation
between the
1996 and 2000 data.
We're going to use linear
interpolation.
So let me draw a line.
You could always do this much
more exact if you have better
tools or a spreadsheet.
But I'm going to draw a line,
and I want to get 1997.
This is 1997.
It's going to be right
over there.
If we use linear interpolation,
we are
interpolating between
that data point
and that data point.
It's a linear interpolation.
We assume It's a linear
trend between the two.
So this looks like it's-- let me
go all the way over here--
looks a little bit more
than 12, maybe
13% is my best estimate.
Now part 5.
Use the data from example 2--
same example right here-- to
estimate the percentage of
pregnant smokers in 2006.
There isn't any 2006.
This chart ends at 2004.
So we have to use linear
extrapolation with the final
two data points.
So this here you're going to
see the difference between
interpolation and
extrapolation.
Interpolation, you are
estimating between two data
points you already knew.
Extrapolation, we're going to
take the final two data points
and we're going to continue
that line.
We're going to extrapolate
So if you were to just continue
this line between the
final two data points,
it might look
something like that.
So if you had 2006 out here--
these are going up by two, so
2004, 2006-- we extrapolate
this line.
The percentage of women smoking
might be, well it
looks a little bit under 10%.
So maybe 9.5%.
Once again, it's just
an estimate.
But we're just extrapolating
the trend.
We're assuming the
trend of the last
two data points continues.
Then using that, it would
be around 9.5% in 2006.
Now maybe, that's not definitely
the only prediction
you could make.
You could extrapolate based on
all of the data and get a line
that looks something-- let me
try to do it a little bit
better than that-- that looks
something like that.
Then this line would predict
a lower smoking rate.
So it depends on what data you
use, what you're using to do
your linear model with, and
how you're extrapolating.
But anyway, hopefully you
found this useful.